[Music]
hey folks so um i'm going on vacation
next week and in an effort to try and
actually enjoy
my time off uh i threw together
something kind of quick
for
for this week so um
how about a tour of the shooting area
it's also where i do the editing
it's my office
and it's a disaster welcome to adhd if
you
didn't realize how rough
it can get
okay put a little more light on it so
why don't we start
with what's over here so over here we've
got
two out of three of my lighting rigs
so got that one up there right over
there is where i actually shoot i'll get
over there in a bit so i've got that one
this one
the switch i've had these for a while
i've had this lighting set up for over
10 years so the switches on this don't
work anymore they they are locked and
kind of frozen in the on position so
this gets turned on by being plugged in
and so it's currently unplugged so i
can't turn it on for you
and there behind it is the white board
that has
not gotten nearly as much use uh as i
had hoped um after getting it
um i really thought i was gonna use it
more than i did but because of partly
because of where i ended up storing it
and what i'm
actually using it for now which i'll get
to
uh it's a pain in the butt to get out so
i have to really commit to it
that's just a backdrop just because i
didn't feel like just having blank walls
all over the place
uh
over here
is the old flat cap
anyone who's been watching me for long
enough remembers this thing but yeah if
i ever feel the need to get i do still
grab it every now and then it's just
right there
um over here we have uh a piece of art
that i commissioned that is a huldra
commission that at a comic con you'll
see a number of commissioned art pieces
on the walls as we go now as i mentioned
this place is a
is a freaking disaster um so a lot of
what's on the floor
is related to stuff that i am working on
getting out the door related to the
novel so
there's you know there's a whole bunch
of of tubes that the um
that the maps for people who qualified
high enough to get uh
to get a signed copy of the world map
those are in there those have to go out
i've got envelopes some of which i have
filled in the addresses for some of
which i haven't yet
um that i need to mail books out in
but that's what that is now you may have
wondered what the deal with this is so
this
this
rig is just
something that came with the green
screen that i have that boy you think i
don't use the
the whiteboard much i really don't use
the green screen anymore but anyways
so this is just a just a
just sort of a thick blanket
and that's just to um cut down on
voice rebounding i have neither the time
nor the money to sound proof this room
so i put that there and that's basically
directly behind where the camera usually
is so that my voice is being immediately
coming into contact with this and not
ricocheting off the walls
so there's that
um
i'm not going over the mess that's
over there okay so over here
we've got
the computer
ring light behind it for when i am
streaming
i used to be able to stream from my
shooting location but i was back when i
was on a laptop and so i can't anymore
we've got this
this
i actually bought this is a print
that uh was of a of an image that was
drawn by a friend of mine in high school
so yeah this is a high school artist i
don't know if he's still
doing our his name is phil lacelle
last i knew he was still doing art and
was selling it so
that's cool stuff and over here another
commissioned art piece it's furiosa
heck yeah and there's uh there's little
random things like i've got my um
get it in light here yeah
got my flat
oh there's still something in there
yep that's water
ah what else we got with us we got what
else we got so we've got this light here
just to reflect a little bit more light
around the room just so that um i've got
a little more light coming in from the
side
and also some other stuff
these are
uh both from the same artists
you have the silence and of course
goes with the gozerian
[Applause]
are you a god
i'm not showing you the floor you've
seen enough glimpses of it we've got
so i bought this stuff and i used them
uh for a couple of tick tocks a while
back i really should get some proper use
uh
out of these but
if you've seen the movie us
the um
uh god like jordan peele movie
so these these are not real sheers these
are 3d printed but this is
the shears
uh and i've also got
the uh the gloves i suppose this is a
good time to actually
set this thing down and maybe consider
going over some of the specifics
that are going on over here so why don't
we give that a go now most of this stuff
is just all things that you know you see
on a regular basis
i haven't identified a lot of this stuff
in a while though so let's see if we can
go through it now
here's a big thing
a fair chunk of this
is stuff that was sent to me as gifts
from
people who uh you know even people i
know uh in person
people who i've met but aren't local and
people who are just fans who have sent
stuff to the po box there was a healthy
mix in here i am not going to remember
everything that was sent to me by people
and i'm not gonna remember who to name i
have a crap memory for that so
understand if you see anything on here
that you sent to me i'm super grateful
that's why it's up here i'm not gonna
remember to shout you out i'm sorry
but in any case so what we've got over
here is we've got bun bun from sluggy
freelance so you can all you can just
barely see
uh in here actually you know what hang
on see in there you've got
uh queen alien in the back who you can
basically never see
also back there is gizmo who
is not super visible either just because
of how deep
uh into the shelf he is um
that's one that's one of the things i'm
debating is
uh
either getting like fairy lights in
there to to light them up a bit so you
can actually see them or putting
something a little bit more colorful but
in any case you know we've got funkos
for characters like fixie felix and the
kerber lamb man
uh we've got ein we've got i've got
multiple
little lego figures scattered around
i've got 13th doctor i've got wonder
woman i've got poison ivy uh over here
behind me i'll show you the stuff over
here in a little bit i'm not gonna get
through all this i'm gonna try though
i've got multiple adipose
um little guys sort of smattered around
we've got multiple um
forest spirits from princess mononoke
smattered around as well uh this was uh
sent to me that someone made it's a
genderfluid tardis
um
this
i don't really know how to explain this
okay so this if you've ever seen the
golden girls
you remember when stan made like a
traffic cone
monkey
homemade
support thing like for his emotional
support
that's what that is um we've got some
tiny little dinosaurs we've got raf
because raff's my boy so he gets top
shelf um but you'll find the other
turtles are around here we got
michelangelo down here
you know it's down there donatella
donatello's over on the other side
um we have a zydrate bottle just behind
uh
felix if i can get this out without
knocking anything over whoo
yes
because xidrate comes in a little glass
vial
so we've got that this is what i'm going
to spend most of the time doing
don't knock over don't knock over don't
knock over okay
shift you back
stuff does fall off this on occasion
we've got one of numerous bat womans
we've got a harley quinn i mentioned ein
uh we've got
uh louisa who is one of the newer
editions
uh over here but we've got
r2d2 more adipose uh weeping angel
another
uh batgirl we have peter capaldi's
doctor we've got
we've got fozzie and a hoodie
we have a drd from
uh firescape we have vinsklortho that's
the keymaster we have more dinosaurs we
have a a one-up power-up we have sort of
a
sort of a fae a bit of fey art sort of
you know wings and horns and we have a
little dachshund back there we have no
face who is another uh figure who you
can barely see in a lot of the videos um
from spirited away we've got cami from
um
street fighter we got a little dragon we
got another wonder woman
and of course we've got a tardis more
batgirl
a little dog thing that my kiddo made
for me
uh terminator helmet a bigger
michelangelo there's a poison ivy
there's a very small
sonic screwdriver a bigger forest
spirit and uh and a tiger now down at
the bottom is stuff that pretty much
never shows up on camera which is why
it's not nearly as cramped or uh
organized but we have down here
we have stuff like eddie izzard
wunderbar
uh we got a little book of matches some
more dinosaur stuff we have these i have
these for five of the doctors i've got
um 13th third fifth fourth and second
those are something that uh has have
been sent to me over time
i've got um oh god oh i've got my
maverick back here
so i had this for ages before i finally
pulled apart pulled it apart and gave it
a custom paint job and put it back
together i'm actually quite happy with
it
um
but
that i suppose that's worth bringing up
the uh
one of the long-term projects i now have
another one that i've gotten since
which is this sucker
which i would really like to
take apart spray paint the pieces and
put back together
but i've not found the time or the
motivation to do so but i'm looking
forward to when i do
to me that's half the fun of getting
nerf gun stuff is uh
is
making them look even cooler i say one
of the best things like i've done it
with one so far but i really like the
results on that oh and i've also got um
like these are all fake so youtube don't
give me crap about weapons
i have a
fake
flintlock
pistol
which i picked up at a um
uh red fair
ages ago this is one of the earliest ren
faires that i picked that up from
the empty cam what is this
oh this is oh this is sort of a custom
little when i say custom somebody hand
drew stuff on it that was from when i
was in the odd couple
back in
2017 holy crap
that was the last time i was on a play
all right we've got stuff on the other
side so let's
actually before we do that
i mentioned there was something i was
using the whiteboard for uh it's housing
the mic because the mic arm is attached
here
so
the main thing this whiteboard now gets
used for
is uh to hold the mic in place
um because i don't know you may have
noticed uh i've got the blue yeti over
there um which i'll use for a lot of my
streaming stuff but this is a hype mic
this is an apogee hype mic which i like
better for my uh
for my stuff
you know that i actually do for the
channel so over on this side uh we have
this little fake uh movie trophy thing
we've got a tiny little tenth doctor we
have a big old totoro 13th doctor
there's a little uh lego
um uh poison ivy i mentioned before
um the little lego figures actually my
my partner liz
uh got me those
um because they're lego figures of
characters that i have cosplayed so
that's why it's
um poison ivy uh 13th doctor and wonder
woman
um so the there's a heart somebody made
for me this this rainbow dragon uh was
made for me um and sent to me so we got
donatello in there this is i people ask
every now and then it's been a while
though this is a touch a coma from ghost
in the shell
um and then oh we've got hup
from
the uh
age of resistance the dark crystal age
of resistance um we have zan
uh just behind harley quinn we have a
little we have a little riddler
duck
rubber duck
um
and like you're probably not well some
of you are probably noticing the dust
level on there i apologize like that's
another thing just it's just hard for me
to wrangle my
adhd brain and pull that together but
we've also got fix it felix
and uh and a bit of commission art that
i had done of scorpio
up top
that there's all the um
sonic screwdrivers there's a little um
tardis stress ball there's tamaleon
that's my dragon
um and then there's the weapon rack
which
it's got size it has a battle axe like
pretty much none of these are battle
ready again to be clear this is these
are like show pieces
um then we have the cutlass we have two
different samurai swords we have the
rapier we have a kendo practice sword
and then up at top
that's the claymore
guarded by a facehugger as you do
we have this is actually a doll of me
um like i think you might be able to see
like some of the hairs are lighter
colored it's meant to uh reflect uh my
different colored hair there we have the
tonberry with the um
uh gender fluid i think i think i'm
actually to get in here i'm gonna have
to take this off the stand
let's see so we've got the tumbler we
have some stickers here that i don't
know if anybody ever sees
uh that's me that is my
my burlesque sticker
uh me in chibi form we've got scorphuma
of course
uh back there is the uh the lava lamp
that people uh seem to enjoy
behind that
lobster we got the joker next to that
um and oh we've got this quote which is
still my favorite doctor who quote it
doesn't matter to whom the cruelty is
directed the cruelty itself is wrong
somebody made that for me after i said
how much i love that quote and it's
wonderful that is just a random
assortment of crap back here because um
you know it's never shown on camera
because my fat ass is blocking it
an empty star wars space punch can
because i thought the cam was cute yes
that is a puppet version of me or at
least me back when i
thought i was a dude so you know kind of
a kind of an outdated version of me but
yeah there's that
so this is a space that i
uh
spend
uh an awful lot of my time in
because i shoot here and i edit over
there
so
i spent a lot of time in here i'll tell
you i'm really glad for this
because for a long time i was doing all
of this out of my bedroom
like i i i had other rooms but like they
were guest rooms and i just i hadn't it
took a while for me to like get all the
energy to move all this stuff because
like this entire setup had to move this
all used to be in my bedroom which
long term was not good for me because
that meant i was shooting
editing and sleeping
all in the same space so the exact same
place i was supposed to be going to rest
was also the exact same space that my
brain was telling me you should be
working
that wasn't good for me it's a lot
better for me having this as a separate
room now um
but yeah like i said this is this is
this is low rent content right here but
i'm on vacation or at least i was in the
week immediately prior to this by the
time you see this i'll actually probably
be back um but i didn't want to
um
you know hammer myself for taking the
time off and i didn't want to come back
and immediately be buried in work so
this is what you get this time hope you
enjoyed it
understand that all of this is made
possible by patreon support
um
and your help is greatly appreciated i
wouldn't be
taking a vacation
i wouldn't have a room dedicated to this
i wouldn't i wouldn't be talking to you
right now if it wasn't for that kind of
support
but even if you're not able to do that
like share subscribe all that helps
links in the description for other stuff
if you want to send me something to see
if i'll put it up in the
up in the uh the shelf
the po box is down in the description
the address for that
but um
excuse me
don't worry too much about it
because what i really want you to
remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
you are loved
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings
and until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
all right i've got thanks to give for my
patreon supporters robin moore zubin
fulla turak the thing that goes doink in
the anime oliver b linda walters
imudelki the oatha boyd tt for nobulax
the poodle zach idolin tracy scrabbit
angry casper
toku bl whovian adam rdl taylor shane
ross shayla gourley and brendan larose
the rats and i thank you
[Music]
now
[Music]
bye
[Music]